MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Hi, and
welcome to this video, where
we will show you all the new,
exciting stuff in Google Play
Services 4.3.
If you're new to
Google Play Services,
you have come to the right place
because Google Play Services
rocks.
For you as a developer,
this is great news
because you can get your
hands of all the latest
blazing, hot stuff we
develop here at Google.
And incorporate into your apps.
Let's look at the
highlights of this version.
First of all, we'll show
you a brand new Address API,
then we'll go through
some exciting new features
of the Google Play
Games services.
We'll also cover the Google
Analytics and Google Tag
Manager APIs, which are also
brand new to the Google Play
Services family.
And we'll round it off
this time by showing you
new stuff in the Google
Drive Android API.
Let's get started.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Ladies and gentlemen, that's
right, we've got a new API.
Let's welcome the Address
API with a round of applause.
MALE SPEAKER 1:
Get back to work.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Yes sir.
How many of you have
tried to buy something
on the internet
from your smartphone
and then come to
the part where you
need to fill out the
delivery address.
Argh, nightmare experience.
Big fingers on small keys.
But of course, if you want to
ship to your current location,
then you can use
the location API
to fill out the address,
which makes things easier.
MALE SPEAKER 2: But
what if you're at work
and want to ship
it to your home?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
That's exactly when
the Address API
comes to the rescue.
With the API, your app can
present a user interface,
which displays all addresses
registered by the user.
The user can then
select an address,
such as John Smith in the
example on the picture,
and voila.
The address will be made
available to the awesome bike
store app to complete
the purchase.
There is no more messing around
with thumbs and small keys.
Isn't that great?
Shopping on your smartphone
just became a walk in the park,
thanks to Google Play Services.
Now over to Google
Play Game services,
mobile gaming is
bigger than ever
and we're continuing to pack
new features into this API.
With this release we've
introduced Game Gifts,
which allows player to send
virtual in-game requests
to anyone in their Google+
Circles or through player
search.
A player can now
send a Wish Request
to ask another player for
an in-game benefit or item.
And another player can
send a Gift Request
to give an item, or
benefit, or something,
making both players
happy in the end.
This feature complements the
multi-player functionality
released earlier and will
enhance the social engagement
between players in your games.
An example of using gifts
is to request more lives
from your friend, in case
the last round of playing
did not go so well.
Psst.
This little video used the
LiquidFun Physics Engine.
You should so much check it out.
So great stuff from the
Google Play Services,
be sure to use them
all in your game.
Let's now move over to the
Google Analytics and Google Tag
Manager APIs.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
And ladies and gentlemen, that's
right, these are all new APIs.
Let's welcome the Google
Analytics and Google Tag
Manager APIs with a
round of applause.
MALE SPEAKER 1:
Get back to work.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Yes, sir.
So these APIs have actually
existed as standalone APIs,
but have now been fully
integrated into the Google Play
Services API family.
This is great, since this
reduces the memory footprint
of your app, and these APIs
become accessible side by side,
with all the other
ones, ready for you
to use to create that shiny app.
So let's look at what
these APIs contain.
We'll start off with the
Google Tag Manager, which
lets you use tags in your apps
instead of hard-coding values.
These tags are then
substituted for values
that you have stored in the
Tag Manager at run time.
This can, for example, be used
to manage background colors
of your app, game settings,
and localization settings.
Since the values of the tags
are stored in the Tag Manager,
this eliminates the need
to push your entire app
from Google Play again.
You can simply change the value
of the tag in the Google Tag
Manager.
That brings us over to
the Google Analytics API.
And if you haven't used
Google Analytics before,
I strongly encourage you
to take it for test ride.
Google Analytics allows you
to get detailed statistics
on how your app is being
used by your users.
For example what
functionality of your app
is being used the most or
which activity triggers
the users to convert from
an advertisements app
to a paid one.
So that stuff can be
pretty, pretty good
to know to get your
users happy, but also
to get your next
month's paycheck.
So be sure to check the
Google Analytics API out
because it can really provide
lots of valuable information
to you.
Which brings us to do
Google Drive Android API.
As you may know, Google
Drive Android API
was officially released in the
last version of Google Play
services, and it's
often a flying start
with a number of
API enhancements.
First off is pinning.
You can now pin
files that should
be kept up to date locally.
This ensures that the app
can work with these files,
even when the user is offline.
Then we have app folders
which allows your app
to create files which are no
longer visible to the user.
For example, to store temporary
files in a photo editor,
this is the same function
as the application data
folder in the Google Drive API
that have existed for a while.
With this version, we also
have Change Notifications,
which makes it possible
to register a call back,
and receive a notification when
a file or folder is changed.
This means that
you no longer need
to query drive continuously to
check if the data has changed,
just put the Change
Notification on it
and the API will call
you when it happens.
And then we've also made
a number of enhancements
to metadata information,
which is something
you can never get enough of.
Well, to satisfy that craving,
you may have for metadata,
you should be happy
to hear that we've
added a bunch of new
fields in this version.
So that's it for this release
of Google Play Services,
but stay tuned because we've
got lots more coming up.
Now it's your turn.
So go out there and
create great apps,
and don't forget to
tell us all about it.
[BIKE BELL]